thinking about you all romero did did
rogan you ever you hear what rogan said
about ul
where they looked at his eyes the the
muscle
was three times thicker than the normal
muscle in someone's eyes oh weird i
don't believe that that's cool
that's what the doctor said
yeah is there any bigger freak i do yeah
he's a genetic
he's in his 40s right he's a freak yeah
he's 40 something remember he got kicked
so many times in his leg and i think by
a sonia and they're like it's your leg
okay he goes gets up and starts dancing
he's like yeah he's like superman he do
backflips
he's a he's a friend you don't get a
better athlete than i don't yeah
i mean he's never been a champion but
yeah sure world champion wrestling twice
uh not in the ufc never no but beat cal
sanderson yeah yeah i think he would be
a world champion if he wrestled he
didn't want to get tired and that was so
interesting
yeah because i feel like he could put
everybody on their back at will and he
doesn't like he could do what khabib
might not translate
yeah you don't think so
i would feel like i feel like he could
do to guys what khabib does to guys in
terms of like
take you down eventually why
just khabib styles that's what he does
isn't it the same i mean they didn't oh
that diocean wrestling's different than
what yeah did
and also it's a cardio thing too you
know what's awesome always gets tired
he does get tired
doesn't want to wrestle nothing how much
what's his weight that's interesting
205 now he's fighting uh phil davidson
bellator the other thing is that you
have to be careful with what people say
dagestani wrestling and some great
wrestlers but khabib is so special like
there are i've seen i've watched augusta
wrestlers or people from that area with
the same style that don't do that don't
put guys in their back there's a lot
that do there are packages
there's so many people how do you avoid
making chef you know he's going to be
the champion yeah
how else used to be i loved it houston
was great um
did you link up with whiskey pete i
didn't you see him at all no i hung with
dan crenshaw
nice nice guy and by the way uh i'm i'm
not a far right [ __ ] you know i have
no idea what his politics are he was
just you know his politics i mean what i
like about him
well for me i'm not a i'm not far left
and i'm not far i'm not right i'm i'm
moderate i don't think i've ever
politically i'm moderate i just am like
i'm pro
gay men depend on the role
all that [ __ ] yeah yeah pro you know um
i'm pro-choice i'm one of those guys but
um christopher's a legit but crenshaw
crenshaw is a [ __ ] guy who i i know
i like that he's reasonable so it's out
he took on the people saying the
election was stolen he was like this is
[ __ ] no it's not yeah and he got a
lot of [ __ ] for that so that's that's
what i know about him i don't know about
the other i haven't looked into his
[ __ ] policies i know he's republican
in houston i think he also got [ __ ]
he's about the vaccine as well
well no i think he's pro vaccine his
name i don't know yeah so am i so the
[ __ ] am i i mean in terms of like i
think i believe in science yeah
but
what's funny is that i posted uh uh you
never know if when a hero's gonna come
out well i'm not saying he's a hero
because he's a politician i'm saying
he's a hero because he did five [ __ ]
tours and lost his insight his goddamn
what the [ __ ] and then kept being he's a
legend and after he lost his sight he he
went back into the seals and did other
[ __ ] he's a monster like come on so what
you got lit up and i don't know i don't
look at yeah yeah but my friend
i've been defending you for the past
hour i was like on what yeah like i
never know
so i'm fired up yeah i'm a little fired
up because i don't like being captured
as some far-right republican [ __ ] off
i'm moderate as [ __ ] yeah but you should
expect that if you post a picture with
of crenshaw yeah we're so political now
we're so [ __ ] political i don't
really post a picture with [ __ ] trump
you should expect some backlash he's not
trump and he's a great guy he's not
trump he's a thoughtful dude very
thoughtful dude and a good guy just said
come on man i know you're smart on this
don't give up
i mean this is where i get it maybe
maybe uh people are just so
anti-republican in general and link him
to trump i get that i'm not a trump
supporter any republican
trump yeah yeah well i i've been very
clear on
i mean you got it gives a [ __ ] yeah who
cares you should expect that i know i i
i actually if i take a picture with
pelosi i would expect a little
background right yeah i think of him as
different i think him as a veteran who
lost his eye that's what i think a navy
seal he did a [ __ ] but it's all of it
but he's a he's a politician yeah he's a
representative
congressman
yeah it's just interesting we are we're
in a political world i was like whoa did
he show you his uh iowa yeah yeah he
showed you we hung out afterwards just
grabbed beers and stuff very down earth
guy and he had a fake eye with the uh
tried and the seal
yeah does he take it out and like show
you no no but it was there at first i
didn't know what it was it looked so
often and he was like it's just the
truth remember he hit kind of mainstream
because uh davidson made fun of him yep
yeah
oh and he went super viral after that
have you seen his eye no it's so he
there's pictures of it online it's so
dope he has uh the trident i know i've
seen the try i'm saying i want to see it
without all that [ __ ] i think there's
i've seen the fake guy oh you want him
to take that thing out
what the what'd it do
with
there you go dope yeah that's a captain
america one
oh he has different ones he likes
switches out oh hell yeah
i like his ipad he looks [ __ ] sick
yeah he takes it off you know when he
goes out to drink it i think it must be
a pain to have it on all the time but
the eye patch i think so it's a
conversation
is he married and he's he's got problems
with this otherwise you see it there uh
poor guy yeah he he that's a guy anybody
i know who [ __ ] sacrificed their eyes
for my country
he's okay
i'm not talking about politics
i'm not a trump supporter don't don't
don't link me into that [ __ ] i'm just
saying you gotta calm down i i will i
know i'm a little fighter what would you
do cause i gotta enter
we know i gotta go with you i got nine
yeah
the other side's gonna get upset it's
like if i post a picture with the boston
red sox i'm assuming the yankee fans are
gonna talk about it yes yeah yeah it
didn't dawn on me really yeah i'm
[ __ ] clueless 60. i know i i'm not
i'm just i don't know i didn't think of
it that way i thought of it i think it
was a navy seal who lost his eye i don't
follow his my politics i don't follow
texas politics yeah yeah all right it's
okay and and it's funny how you breathe
yeah right okay breathe you don't have
to prove anything to us i get too much
sleep we don't have hair yeah we get too
much sleep and coffee we didn't write
anything
already
i don't want to go what the [ __ ] you
doing brian unless johnny did it with
his like troll account or something like
that i just want to go i just got energy
i can't believe you didn't assume people
are going to send hate when you post a
picture politician though
yeah if you post that's just territory
yeah like there's teams that matter it's
just
teams everyone's team maybe we've always
been that way but it feels strong now
look at social media you see it now
social media makes it it's really trump
that polarized the country so hard like
that dude just you know
i think more to it than that we're in
teams before that yeah we were we always
have been well then afghanistan we're in
teams now jesus christ
yeah i keep going down the rabbit hole
that i don't know what i would have done
i do think that that pull out that
sloppily was just probably not it was
just it was just bad management but the
to leave afghanistan make sense you know
especially for americans yeah but to do
it the way they did it's a little dicey
no no no it's a little dicey well
leaving 11 000 americans behind well we
don't even know what you think more than
11 years and all that equipment you know
yeah
how was your hike with fred durst how
about we're supposed to we're supposed
to work out this morning guys sorry guys
hiking with fred durst i said i'm sorry
is it
1999. first of all they've been killing
it
limpiske how yeah just touring and doing
the shows coming out a new album and
stuff working on new albums they have a
new album they're working on it yeah oh
it's not out not out yet okay
yeah there he is
dude he's my age right but he's sober
now completely you know i i know him
because so olympus he can't stores
because of uh cover 19 concerns okay um
sucks
yeah uh i'm going back to the door
uh go back jane cause he looks different
now you know i did a golf charity thing
with him you do yep
see the one says show's new look gin you
see the headline
oh the uh where the
he calls it the pool guy
is what he calls it
wow that's a wig right yeah
so he just comes out like that with the
mustache people were loving it
they were going crazy for them that was
a uh was that lollapalooza so you didn't
go on a hike with them no i said no one
no one woke up early i'm the only early
bird
but what time did they say you were
going to hike 8 30.
i woke up at 6 00. no one got back to
you no
damn
they were so big back in the day
they're still killing it though and then
they had then he and the lead singer of
creed had beef
and they were going to fight
yeah yeah and he was making fun of the
lead singer of creed you know creed
remember the creed yeah with the worms
what opponent yeah that guy was suicidal
yeah he tried commencement yeah he was
he was yeah
alcoholic yeah i liked him because what
he did was he said all right i'll tell
you what since you're calling me out why
don't you and i fight and we'll give the
money to charity
that's kind of cool and dirty ain't
nothing wrong with a good fight damn
good for him he's doing yeah i'm pretty
sure he's uh completely sober he's lost
weight he's he's down a weird rabbit
hole you know he's like directing movies
and stuff what a movie
um it was one with ice cube and i forget
the girl's name
like big movies and
chill brendan
that's a bummer you didn't get a hike
with them that would have been fun yeah
yeah my boy uh
toby morris is real tight with him so
he's
we were all gonna go she did some tommy
lee stuff the long shots the long shots
that's the one with ice cube hmm
are you familiar with that one
he shot the pole of mud oh yeah but
they'd sign polo mud right
i don't know
you think
how about then we're going to work out
saturday spells uh i got band practice
like what the [ __ ] is going on with this
guy is that is that you singing or
playing an instrument i sing in it how
did your concert go yeah how do you do
it let's talk about chin thanks it was
good it was really good a lot of fun you
got any footage of you on stage
hold on we do have some footage
so it didn't go well it went really well
it really went better than i could have
ever imagined i didn't think anyone
would show up i just didn't that's so
cool yeah and they they said that over
300 people bought tickets that's great
man for a show ever see your daddy got
paid
dad didn't get paid you didn't they paid
for flights and hotel and it was like
remember it was a benefit it was meant
for people with drug addiction and all
that stuff oh that's cool oh hell yeah
it's just a start but good for you yeah
yeah it was incredible chin out here
let's see some video chin i'll pull up
in a bit you guys talk about no no yeah
you could be no no hold on hold on both
of you are weird about your music we are
why why
i don't know why why are you embarrassed
because it's just like why are you
embarrassed i feel like all artists are
like that i don't know the [ __ ] they are
kanye i don't know it's just kanye he's
like that he's like he's like that he's
done three arenas
here's the thing chin
if you're not all the way in and you're
and you're timid and like yeah that's
all right no one's gonna buy tickets
dude i'm not buying a ticket to that
all right first he might be a sensitive
i'm just very shy about this but of
course when i'm performing when i'm on
stage
that's kind of where i can do all that
stuff you're a sensitive shy artist
don't let the bully over here make you
like into like some
i get but i get why i get the same thing
though because yeah it's like it's a way
to express yourself
you want to feel really good about it
and it's just like you guys are more
vulnerable yeah i don't give a [ __ ] i'm
saying you want to go on tour and sell
two come on man you can't be like dude
all right
well that's what singer's doing
all right i mean i guess i had a good
time it was better than i imagined i was
like well how many people sold out 300
people it's like well it sounds like an
awesome time don't be don't be so
bullied you have that let it be but
didn't it sound like you went awful it
was all right well that's chin though
that's his energy
and i asked him i said it was it from
the wrestling match you had i believe
you did a little micro tear and then you
went to sit down yes turn the wrong
that's why i was sure because i was fine
i was walking around i was perfectly
fine and then when i
started editing i was turning around
don't work out and then you don't warm
up and you get up and do that i know
yeah you got a knee bracelet
you tugged on the door too yeah i think
it's when you tugged on the shoulder
broke breaking this is true
king power you guys compromised my power
now now poor chin looks like [ __ ]
johnson yeah
[ __ ] short kings
last time you saw a knee brace over
jeans
it's [ __ ] i told you though it's kind
of dude i had a three hour tour a
walking tour
in ohio because my girlfriend set it up
oh that's after i did this how was that
and then i got a huge rash inside
hey hold on how was that four-hour
walking tour she loves doing that kind
of stuff i mean i don't care what you
think wait how was that kid hold
hours chin yeah or three it was three
hours
and what was the food in ohio uh it was
we literally only had skyline chili okay
uh
belgian waffle skyline and then
something else i forgot it was nothing
and we couldn't even drink we had to
sneak drinks in cincinnati's top ten so
it's in the top ten not the number one
in cincinnati do they have this our crew
right here
holy [ __ ] i couldn't believe it
oh wait she's got a knee brace go back
look at him guys
yeah there's there's like two they kept
checking on my knee too
there we are
oh man
now fellas are the way to go
this is the most tourist thing i've ever
seen i know it was rather die i know you
would i know you would i would [ __ ]
rather
i was just i was laughing the entire
time i couldn't believe it three hours
though the fact that you all took and
skyline chili yeah i know alcohol you
see the video of the tour
there's not the tour video we don't have
a door of twitter oh you mean this way
before you go can i just ask one
question like like
my girl knows better hold on so you walk
through cincinnati with the messed up
name four hours i know but three i've
been to cincinnati a number of times now
now let me ask you this
what was the highlight
what'd you see where you went this is
worth it oh my god how many stupid
questions it wasn't on the tour the
highlight was not on the tour it wasn't
i was i was honestly just laughing that
we were on this tour and there's old
ladies are waiting for girls
i love her she just loves doing this
how old your girl
38.
my mother you know what my mother likes
to go to parades
she likes to stand in a group and watch
the day walk nowhere i'd rather slit my
[ __ ] throat
it's the worst thing i have to take
balloons i had to take a [ __ ] at the
mason day parade and then i was a kid
and i pooed a little bit and then i had
to [ __ ] your pants well and i i was on
my hands and knees on the seat of the
car that's a longer story the point is
let me see the music okay it's super shy
this is why i put my instagram story
whoa
all right
and then this one austin was talking
about kingston jim's blowing kisses
that's where it cuts off but yeah it was
awesome dude it was super cool see i'm
not the same on stage as i'm here right
now i was actually waving and stuff like
that yeah i'm terrified to show you like
my bands why it's because i mean i gave
you a little [ __ ] the other day yeah
because they got band practice man they
sent me this picture
it looked like they were like he was
[ __ ] like
who's your there's a police officer
wait who's your hero who's your lead
singer hero who would you if you could
that's tough you'd be one guy lead
singer hero please don't say no
gallagher no frankie lyman
uh
from the teenagers
old school doo-wop
beautiful voice yeah but yeah you don't
want to get a music thing with him yeah
i know i was like i got it i was like i
was like you might not even
listen i love that you i love that you
pulled that name out that's [ __ ] that
means yeah history you got history but
you can't like make fun of me no i want
to see it man i want you i want to know
what you guys do don't why are you so
ashamed of it
you guys both are talented as [ __ ] but
it's like it's just hardcore and it's
it's if that's what you're into yeah
but you would look would you bully hey
dude you know what i celebrate hey you
know what though did you get a chance
like you're you're super critical oh and
then you're like whatever you're into
yeah
it's exactly not support your music
career
always chin too what
i know you can't make fun of me though
you got to turn it down cause it's a
little loud all right let's see this uh
hey until i get on the back four hymns
promo code bgb
free month supply
i need it
we get look at [ __ ] chappelle go
[Applause]
[Music]
that guy's a mascot
have you done any shows no that's a
cover song we've been doing a cover
you've done they've done shows they're
huge yeah oh yeah yeah you you've don't
you guest started something like that
but your band hasn't done [ __ ] no we
haven't done anything yet we got like
yeah we're gonna come out with like a
demo and stuff we don't have a name yet
we're still oh yeah oh let me help with
this okay look at you
excited
let me help with the name
what are you gonna say i'd have to hear
more of the music okay so you want to
but if it's it's three white guys than
you uh no it's
uh
the guys actually used to be
the band for uh kill tony call it three
whites and me
i like that
do you know how the white guys are
always trying to keep up with tiger
woods he's the leader
tiger woods the band
oh
wow yeah full-on band oh yeah those that
they get i know that guy so before i
kill tony yeah the huge four-way tony
you guys are punk rock i know why are
they wearing masks i'm annoyed that's
not punk rock i know it was for the
picture it's fun that seems cool yeah
good because it's like i'm the one that
like i'm the one without a mess because
i'm the singing that's a good picture
actually yeah that's cool i look good in
it um
you really want to come up with a name
yeah man yeah actually you're actually
good at making up names why don't you
come up with a name that's a sound that
nobody's ever had
how did you laugh how did you get there
when it comes to marketing
what's up guys we're somewhere yes dude
and everybody's like
do that you guys practice how often
um every sunday once a week yeah how
about this every sunday ah
like seven days
make him stop that's pretty cool
he's gonna mess up your band
dude that's a [ __ ] amazing name
it kind of sounds like so what chin
when's the next one for you in little
brows phoenix phoenix at a place called
the rebel lounge rebel september 18th
and then the weekend after that uh in
texas
on my tour there you're in the san
antonio and we're going to be in austin
i think swan something
same 24th 25th 25th so hopefully we can
see you at one of the how far is those
places i don't even know not that far
not that far driving that would probably
hour and a half right b that'd be cool
wait for it
i think uh i think i'm off that weekend
i'll go to phoenix oh dude
you could show up hour 25 that's what
i'm like
yes
i would love to get on there and just be
with tambourine and just just just yeah
me and brian in the back
i'll be the cowbell dude
no i feel like no no just no not on the
bring it drums
yeah i really do just call it you should
try it i know i bet you guys
but here's the thing
did you tell me you could play drones
yeah
okay he's got he's got the one two three
four you have uh drums at the house no i
don't have german i have guitars i have
a load i have a load of guitars i think
we should be the tambourine boys we come
out and you're like now it's time to
bring out the tambourine boys yeah but i
won't do that but i'm a better guitarist
than i am a drummer though i wanna do
the cover of ocean avenue
if it's hardcore let's do age of quarrel
by the crowmax you really down for that
[ __ ] yeah dude [ __ ] yeah do you think
you can pull off like something that's
vocal
did you really
i mean i have a song i told you but i'm
working on this oh yeah we still haven't
heard your song look at this a lot of
musical talent and it's hardcore too
it's hardcore yeah but is it something
like shut up stupid or something like
that huh it's gonna call shut up shut
the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up yeah i was
way off that's not the thing shut up
about what though yeah i mean we can
play it but i think i should wait for
this why are you a [ __ ] out of your
music too
hey you know what you know what it is
hey you know we're all scared to show
you our towel
you'd have to hear that's why i want to
see it no but you'd have to hear it
because i don't know but i can't see it
yeah but i'm not you don't i don't have
it on video i have it on i i only have
the vocals i'm going to make this like a
you have like a recording oh yeah yeah i
want to hear it all right here i'm going
to send it hold up to the mic let's send
the chin i'll send it to chin who who uh
who put it together for you my buddy
mark he's mark so you didn't write it
yeah i did
i wrote it
so you get a you get a writing credit on
the yeah i wrote all that i didn't write
the music but i i i wanted the lyrics i
told him the kind of music i wanted like
i wanted i wanted something specific
here brian's like dude i'm not [ __ ]
far right listen i came with a song shut
the [ __ ] up and forget your vaccine
i'm a pro vaccine shut the [ __ ] up
liberal
i am not anticipating about this
i am not anti-vex we are the people
i can't wait to hear that this is so
all right my computer or my phone bro
yeah and don't be shitty about myself
i'm sensitive it's shitty we're gonna be
no it's not don't be shy you know you
can't stop him
huh he's going to this [ __ ] he's going
to say but here's my thing with all this
white
music
i have an idea but i don't want to talk
about it it was just something i was
doing i was like [ __ ] bored sure
you got to check your email i had to
request access from your google drive
his worldwide debut this is okay shut up
with brian cowan no man
brandon
what do i do here uh you have to check
your email and say yes
click on the link and just uh accept his
email
google drive is how you're gonna gonna
be your artist name brian mandragon
um oh that's a good idea
[ __ ] man hey i said it first i know
that's here you gotta give me that
credit where is it i mean i thought he
hurt you
boom
dude i'm gonna call it benny everyone
hear about the music
that's not true dude that's because
you're super you're hypercritical dude
shinzo come see my music
september 18th
i guess it's gonna be fun is that your
bashful character
hey do you have any songs nope
business is booming i don't need music
dude could you even sing could you do
anything don't want to man too busy with
all my other [ __ ]
you know right it out yeah hey
it's not because business isn't good for
me i can't i'm too busy
well why would i write music because it
opens up some stuff in you we got to get
you a drum set why would i write music
we got to give you advice do you have
any music in you or are you dead inside
dude i have no music in me wow i do six
shows a week papa business is boo i
can't write songs that's not my asset
that's not my skill set oh it is mine
apparently yeah
so you wrote the lyrics i don't like
your lack of support from anybody hey
hold on
joshua
no i don't like your lack of support
you know what let me hear the song let's
just go for it yeah i'm feeling like i'm
not able to get it from your shitty
right can you keep google drive do you
have anything anyone else have the
actual audio file just play it on your
phone yeah wasn't that the thing i was
just letting your phone yeah just
letting your phone open you're sending
me the actual the google drive link i'll
just i'll get it no just play it off put
your phone and hold it the mic because
we'll be able to hear it i don't think
he knows that
let me see i think i can get it to chen
tonight
i just wish you'd play hold it to the
phone dude
just hold the phone like this and then
we can jam
i won't do it
it's not the way it is not the way my
art is is it no this is the demo this
isn't the mastered version this is the
demo
this is the demo okay see this one you
know who came out with a slapper album
john mayer have you heard it
uh
good yes yes
yeah that guy can [ __ ] i love you so
have you seen it it's like eight it's
like everyone
it's telling him live lewis
i just listened to that oh it's good
okay him live it's almost like it's like
who the [ __ ] like apparently makes me
want to throw my guitar away he's a
beast on the guitar
i don't know it's insane what he does
live you know he's a north star for
fashion for uh males too like his
fashion stupid yeah your brother was
that's the best watch collection of
anything yeah he loves watches by far in
a multi-million dollar watch your
brother says something like this
japanese uh clothing line that he likes
to wear a lot yeah
um
i forget what it's called i forget the
name but yeah you know what i'm talking
about all those like uh the all the top
sellers yeah
he's a fashion he's so dumb
he's so undeniable yeah like i was
listening to it and i was in the store
and they were playing and i was like who
is this there goes this have you seen
the video it's all 80s vibe too it's
sick he um
he's like he's gotten so good at guitar
that like
it's not even like it's just like he
just hears sounds and he just makes it
him and that's where the jack white jack
white blows me away jack why can't i
went away though jack white from the
white stripes from
the white stripes yeah yeah
wait do you not listen no no i do i do i
was thinking for some reason jack black
popped up my head no john
jack white's a monster yeah he's a
monster
he's explaining that stuff he goes he
goes there's songs that he writes for
people and there are songs that hit that
are just strictly for him and you could
tell which ones those are for sure
there's so much the body is the
wonderland albums and the songs because
you got i mean yeah you got to sell now
i feel like this cd he made for him like
those albums for him well probably
because he's gotten to a point now to
where it's like he's really essentially
where it's like those earlier records i
don't know i haven't talked to john yet
but jim you'd be so disappointed your
boy uh the lead singer of journey the
filipino guy yeah they did a benefit in
new york like new york's back
and he was singing he was so out of key
oh that sucks i know me and my girl were
like oh yes his journey
it was not good that does happen on
stage because if you don't have the
they're called wedges if they're not
turned on you can't hear your own voice
oh so you're just it's going all the way
it's going out there
but if you had i mean they're so
professional they must have this yeah
the airplane you have to have it just it
didn't sound good man that sucks
i blame the sound guy for that one
yeah it was rough okay i'm gonna have it
sent to me hello cool j crushed it
though he was on there
oh hello yeah did you watch the school
of hard knocks are you watching this uh
dallas cowboy thing i haven't no i saw
the first episode
a couple things two things that i think
are interesting for guys and i want to
know what you guys think first of all if
you have food on your mouth
okay if you have food on your mouth yeah
say you got a little something in your
mouth i don't know if i'm allowed to do
this i can't go
no that's gay yeah no right that's just
a little secret i think it's a mark the
other day yeah no right i didn't like
that but the other thing is um if i go
if it was your birthday
and i got you oh you're talking about
when uh uh
zeke got uh he got on that back stacked
the that fancy bag yeah and that's it
it's sick but it just looked so intimate
and i was like a six thousand dollar bag
he's like i got you this for your
birthday we're best friends well i
thought what kind of bag like
they both make so much money it's a
custom uh
forget the bag that he got him but it's
a custom one it's like cowboy colors
because you know they don't have
carry-ons so it's first well you bought
me a pair of boots yeah for my birthday
you you didn't like that when you gave
his i don't mind it i just think it was
it was very intimate it was very
intimate but you know that's not doing
that his assistant lined all that up i'm
sure yeah i'm sure
yeah i don't think he went all the way
out and bought issue with it i didn't
think she would i just thought it was
interesting i thought that that looks
very evanchee that looks giovanta that
looks very intimate that looked like
oh it was like that no he's kind of like
you know he's in a box he's like here
dude got you this wasn't something did
he pass it off
this was a little bit different how did
he pass really they were they were
getting down to watch them
i'm being a little bit i just thought i
it's not i don't know if that's my
generation i i it's interesting being
nice
like buying a friendly is a really
expensive beautiful gift
that's interesting do you think the
title's too intense brian shut the [ __ ]
up no i don't know there's some songs
dude hey hey
i'm joking around so i don't know if i
would even call it that i'm just [ __ ]
wrong but here's the song seriously play
it hit
oh
it's very chappelle you know what i
think we're missing oh respect people
just don't know how good they got
it you know fashion designers and talk
show hosts are getting in trouble for
creating a toxic work environment and i
was like toxic work environment but they
are working in a chemical plant coal
mine on oil field slaughter house
tanning factory textile mill craft vote
etc so
nothing really about has ever happened
to you so shut the [ __ ] up shut that
[ __ ] up nothing really matters
okay
you know i went to shape this guy's hand
and instead of shaking my hand he made a
prayer gesture and bow a little and then
i noticed he was wearing beads and
sandals but the jesus sandals where you
got to put your big toe into a leather
ring got a tiny buckle at your ankle and
i was like sir are you from tibet and he
was like no i'm from san francisco
did you and dan crenshaw write this
i don't know why people think you're far
right man not far right
how are this thing keep it going no
i think we're good it was good
it goes on musically it's good yeah yeah
the music like that was the point
musician yeah dude got good
you match the energy of like the
instruments like what's going on you're
yelling that's cool yeah yeah i'm a punk
because it's a pumpkin yelling dude
cause that's punk rock a little
bit down
by a little bit of a system yeah dude i
haven't i didn't get that i have a i
have a future i didn't get a system of
down vibe give me like an uh adam
sandler vibe look whenever he makes all
his joke songs live did you get the idea
remember he sent me that the that rapper
who did the
the
the woke lyrics you know what i'm
talking about maybe you sent me yeah no
i didn't i was just i was inspired by
that
i was doing i was writing stand up about
what was bugging me and i i was like and
then my buddy goes why don't you write a
song he's amazing [ __ ] yeah do you shut
the [ __ ] up i was like i was like all
right well
and you're on like time with it and
everything but that was all you know
you're just having fun it's fun yeah
yeah i did it literally i do like it you
did it in his office yeah at a mic and
you lose your voice right he's he's a
musician yeah so he did the guitars and
drums and bass and all that stuff okay
are you gonna do a music video he was
like
i mean maybe it could be funny i'm gonna
i'm gonna tweak the stuff though because
i don't want to come across as you know
far right i mean
he said did you and dan chris shaw write
this
it was you [ __ ]
not in my country magic 2024 and it
counts like i don't i don't get it dude
i don't know
i
or i won't or i'll just stick this stand
up the whole point was to be funny not
to be a musician it's a little political
but you have you have time you mean yeah
i got to stay away from the political
because i'm not i'm once that song that
song
that song is though i was making fun of
the [ __ ] that was going on in l.a that's
all politically the whole thing you know
what i'm saying yeah you don't even talk
politics on stage
not really i what i talk about on stage
is how
how
we're kind of like
whether you're i think you need left
wing and right wing i i don't think you
need extremes but i think you need
conservative and liberal people they
think and they do different things right
like liberals tend to be
people that that create our art right
you need that you need people that
create fashion and stuff and anybody who
thinks otherwise this country is great
because you give people on the left and
the right a voice
yeah and then people in the middle can
figure it out you know but yeah so i'm
i'm i'm not i'm just against censorship
and i'm against i'm for freedom of
speech and allowing all the ideas to
kind of mix
that's what that song says yeah write a
song about it but you know but you never
hear that expression like i'm i'm a i'm
a communist with my family i'm a
socialist with my friends i'm a democrat
with my town and i'm a republican with
my country it's like the idea so in
other words like depending on what what
is the [ __ ] yeah whatever
you call me what do you what do you call
me i'm mostly liberal actually yeah
yeah
i really am write a liberal song dude
and i'm i have a lot
you got your far right song now you got
to write your far left one yes i just
think we're playing both sides i think
this country's getting hijacked by the
[ __ ] crazies on both sides and i
think it's nuts write a song dude that's
what i worry about
[Music]
you're saying write a song about it man
it's [ __ ] split well i'm a writer i
think is there is that guitar still here
no it's not it's at home you play the
guitar well yeah i play guitar better
than that yeah you can play guitar
really yeah
jen did you uh when you guys go on stage
are you just singing
i brought my guitar i played oh you
played oh yeah i played by myself did
you did you do any like r b covers i did
the tracy china song you did fast car
oh that's beautiful did you guys film
any of it i love that song great fun so
some of our he brought a few friends i
brought my girl and a few friends so
they all filmed it in different areas on
their phones yeah but nothing like full
film i don't think yeah but you should
you should do that for phoenix you can
probably find a videographer out that
way pretty easy maybe get hit up now for
sure yeah then i got i could talk to
maybe i could talk to my boy uh tim that
set you guys up maybe dope help you guys
whatever happened trace trapping kind of
did she stop writing music i feel like
she just retired or just stopped for a
long time i don't know
i saw her when she probably fifteen
years ago
she's sprinted in the olympics she
looked like an olympic sprinter still in
the music business but not really active
she's great oh yeah there was something
with her and nicki minaj did nicki minaj
take something from her or she claimed
her no are they in a lawsuit
um i don't know maybe they settled out
of court done i think she was discovered
like she would just play literally on
the street like in in her really
roommate or call oh wow nicki minaj pays
450k to trace the chapman over copyright
infringement lawsuit baby can i hold you
um i don't know that song
baby
i think the lyrics of the fast car is so
beautiful so beautiful
and then the guitar backing it her voice
simple guitar yeah her voice yeah you
ever hear her sing imagine
by by uh john lennon yeah dude oh my god
nobody sings it better wow that's when
you realize you're like oh [ __ ] when
someone
sam smith does a cover of uh
fast car yeah his own style yeah that
version that's crazy
what does he do
i'm sure you have you heard chris chris
stapleton with metallica
with metallica well he sings uh
uh that nothing else matters no really
how are you not familiar with you love
metallica dude
you love chris
i sang chris staples there too you did
yeah you haven't seen the cover that
chris open does it's all over metallica
yeah okay i'll definitely watch you know
how metallica is so anal about their
music of course they must have like
granted him
and let him sing the song
now he's as good as metallica no and do
i am in love with it no but i love chris
april then
is he country yeah big time he's great
you do you listen to zach brown band
nothing that is so trippy
i used to listen to him all the time
you're just listening
play the video okay just a quick one is
he the guy who sings tennessee with his
yes i think so yeah he's a camera yeah
he's great killer and he's a monster on
the guitar too
i already like it it's just not the
original the original's so much better
because i was crunk for this but then i
was like
yeah it's tricky it's tricky to do a
cover of this if it's not going to be
the exact same yeah it's not he makes it
his own way it's just
there he goes
[Music]
take a little break chat with the boys
just getting the care you need to stay
healthy shouldn't be that hard or
expensive for that matter everyone
should be able to afford their
medications check out good rx they help
me find the lowest price on my
prescriptions every freaking time with
goodrx you can instantly compare prices
for your prescription at every pharmacy
in your hood and save up to 80
80 freaking percent good rx is free and
easy to use and many times it's often
cheaper than using your insurance copay
or medicare with goodrx you can find
discounts for your prescriptions at over
70 000 pharmacies like cvs kroger
walgreens rite aid vons walmart and a
lot more good rx is the number one most
downloaded medical app and millions of
americans use goodrx to get affordable
health care every freaking month start
saving up to 80 on your prescriptions
today
go to goodrx.com fighter
that's good rx.com fighter goodrx.com
fighter good rx is not insurance but can
be used instead of insurance in 2020
goodrx users receive an average savings
of over 70 off retail prices it's
goodrx.com
fighter
i like it it's pretty good it's pretty
dope but but i love that other song so
much i'm trying to like battle back and
forth
yeah but but i like the southern grit he
made to it
he definitely made it his style yeah
i'm gonna i'm gonna shazam this
just sam are you from 2008 or you could
just type in
yeah or you go to itunes and type in
chris stapleton yeah why are you doing
the number one song shout out to you
guys
this guy just had this
shazam does anybody know if chris
stapleton's on myspace
i'm going to follow him is he on myspace
or brian hill's like dude with a little
help this guy could [ __ ] make it man
let's get his out here
[Music]
you're the best bry you are you're the
best yeah
dude
i didn't know if shazam was still
usually uh
you don't know the name of the sound i
would have some problems because i would
be doing this stuff and i'd be like is
now i'm trying to add it to my life
just literally
does anyone know how to add it to your
ipod shuffle
crazy
it's just him it's just how do i make
this one of my favorites shazam's not a
thing anymore no i mean people still use
it but usually when you don't know the
song
it's right and obviously it's right it's
right but it's easier like just go to
apple and go i like watching it i like
watching
[Music]
i should oh gosh
that was beautiful that was the time you
got jen it just came out it said august
12th this year it just came out yes it
just came out yeah again it's not bad
but it's not the original it's just so
hard because the other one's so iconic
it's hard to be like uh but i like what
he did i like the southern it's like
his like a southerner
i just heard that song by hugo 99
problems but a [ __ ] ain't one that
jay-z song
you're serious
is that awesome
guys
wait come back i'm sorry all right me
and kyle will fill him from now on wait
oh
[ __ ] man oh god [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] hey [ __ ] you
i thought you serious no it's hugo is
that is that old are you serious is that
an old song
it's all cover i know the song but hugo
that's a new cover right
give me current events
brian's right right
wait is that new though let's see how
long
do that
2014. it's not that old it's not as old
2014 oh yeah
the youtube one came out you tell them
what is this youtube thing he said you
know what i like man
hugo nina brown just it just dropped
[ __ ] i heard it i thought it was they
were playing and i was like what's up
have you ever seen his myspace bro i
was like what's this song oh there are
like 99 problems by hugo i was like oh
dope yeah i came out too i called it
dope you got to look up frankie lyman
now when you get home
shazam
i don't know i don't know music man i do
not know you know different styles and
stuff well you're a musician now though
i am a musician but i'm a new musician
see if hugo cover shut the [ __ ] up
he might have he might
maybe he already wrote it maybe he
already wrote it
[Music]
[Applause]
you think you're in [ __ ] san
francisco enjoying your life
all right
all right dude whatever you checked out
though
but then i tried to did that [ __ ]
guys didn't even hear the whole stop no
we were good and then kyle goes dude
it's giving me a system of the downfalls
everyone's all trying to be all nice
[Applause]
yeah i'm like system of the down dudes
exact same
[ __ ] oh gosh bad idea to play it before
i tweaked it
so [ __ ] you guys
holy [ __ ]
okay
never change brian never change gosh
never change but also change your life
oh yeah
let me just find a good one here i
[ __ ] me up i had to run out of the
room
okay so
if they didn't have that desk in front
of them they would have walked out too
i ran up i'm gonna tighten my face
oh [ __ ] all right so cat sent this over
doing this
i have a theory on why they're doing it
i i think they're doing it because
they're going to sell that's all they're
trying to do for their ideas
they're just listening so only fans is
going to take away this is going to come
up with another thing oh no you'll never
be able to stop it but for only fans of
you know billion dollar company so the
banks didn't they the banks don't want
the money from porn like you know like
bravos and reality kings they can't go
to like chase national bank really no
they do they won't touch that dirty
money so the banks found out that only
fans has you know porno and nudity on it
like we're not touching this [ __ ]
money so they had to change the business
yeah but the business tumbler did the
same thing though right the business
model client no it started as that but
now it's not now now there's a ton of
people on there not like cats on there
cat's not sucking dick on only fans
because that's how it started and then
it got like kind of a bad name because
then when anybody would do it like oh
you're doing porn it's like no only fans
is not born there's cooking shows i
heard that rachel
what's her name yes that's another one
but rachel ray's not showing her tips
tits
she sells dog food i want to join only
fans so i can see what rachel crazy does
so they're just taking away hardcore
porn they're still allowing nudity it's
just a hardcore point that they're gonna
make i think this is the bank the banks
don't want to touch it you know that
yeah because i know that that was weed a
lot of times because it was exactly you
know we like they won't touch
yep they have warehouses of cash
and then they have like security guards
oh damn she really up on them did you
the dock on her is fascinating it's so
weird to me that the the black culture
canceled her because she was actually
helping the cult she was moving
things forward she's helping but she
shouldn't pretend that she's black so
white have you seen like i mean she
could have just done it and been watched
[Laughter]
you can't be you cannot be [ __ ]
transracial
i guess you what's interesting is that
by the same token if you're
what if you feel a different race
that's what she she goes i just i always
my all my friends are black i always
side with the black culture like she's
blonde as [ __ ] she's literally good and
then she got her hair all curled up
the first person was like [ __ ] i i bet
that when as soon as she walked away
from the bar someone's like hey how
black is rachel
she's so loud she gives off some weird
white vibe rachel okay yeah rachel
yeah
so she's doing it only fans but it's
just an inside look oh
has she posted anything or no oh i'm
guessing this is probably
the the cover but it says no post yet so
maybe she's still working on it
i
see monday motivation wednesday work day
friday online lots of other stuff hair
chair conversations yep fridays
i bring the art you bring the wine and
drinks watch me create and discuss my
art wait what's the other random things
foot picks post-media stuff people buy
from my amazon wishlist i think they're
30s she's kids she's not in her 30s she
does have kids oh yeah so embarrassing
so weird yeah it's that stuff that's
bro that was mine and the kids are 43.
so it's tough okay well she's 43. oh she
got a
her books in full color
fantastic she went to
howard university wow yeah pam yeah she
has two kids
langston and franklin go ahead and bring
her up when she was younger have you
seen pictures yeah i saw it before white
white right oh super light oh yeah i've
never seen them
oh well i thought there's i think
there's some mental health illness
freckles
wow there you go
but then go to her there with the baby
with the forehead
oh [ __ ]
she used to darken her skin and her hair
and there you go she put i was too black
for my husband
[Laughter]
it gets better it's just a tough one
like i i feel bad for it because is it
mental health no i just yeah what do you
think
really she loved being this this person
i think that's like okay like she's not
hurting anybody she's not using the
n-word no but but she lied no here's
what the problem is here's the biggest
problem what in a way you're profiting
from other people's struggle so right so
so you're you're she didn't go through
the same trials and tribulations i think
black women have a [ __ ] heart i don't
give a [ __ ] when anybody says overall
black women have had a harder time than
a guy like me in this country yeah just
a fact it's not easy right for a
thousand reasons and she didn't go
through that fire yeah she's she's
capitalizing so it's kind of just if
you're subscribing to it but more
importantly you've done a couple things
you're subscribing to it so you're
you're taking on this character yeah
you're darkening your skin you're you're
curling your hair you're getting into
howard university yeah the best the best
black university um
she got in because she was white i think
she got in as a black woman though as a
person
i don't think so i promise you no wait
wait yeah because when did she start
doing this i promise you she did not i
think i got in there as a white woman
i'd have to see there's probably not a
lot of whites i'm trying to try to find
a picture of her from howard
and then and then on top of that to be
the head of your ncaa champ
chapter yeah in seattle the head is
again like
as somebody who is
oh she didn't go to howard i guess she
went to hell okay she then attended
howard she's she sued howard for racial
justice
she so she did well there too sure i'm
sure she what she did well
yeah so she she probably was like that's
probably where she decided she you know
i see what you're saying like she's
capitalizing on the the you know awful
black if you're if you're a black person
you're gonna be you know you're gonna
have issues a lot of people are gonna be
like listen dude yep
but we're having the same issue women
won't talk about it but there are a lot
of women who are at the forefront of the
feminist movement and now men biological
men who identify as women are coming in
and that is also
there is there is
tension there man there just is
but now if you say that as a as a a lot
of feminists who are lifelong feminists
who fought for the cause
when they say things like
you know
when they say things like look you're
still a biological man and i'm a woman
and there is a difference they get
absolutely destroyed they get
de-platformed and all that stuff yeah i
have a problem with that because i think
that they're just speaking their minds
what happened to that yeah and that's
considered hate speech by a lot of media
companies so now now we're kind of
caught in this weird world where if you
say you identify if you say you feel
that way you can do that sexually you
can't do that racially
okay
but but it's the same criteria what is
the criteria
you kind of gotta go with the same
criteria don't you that though that that
netflix stock they did on her is
fascinating there's excellent i didn't
see it i didn't say it i didn't love it
it's good it's good and you'll feel
you'll feel bad for it of course you i
always feel bad yeah because you know
she you know granted she was trying to
help out the culture and it just gets
taken it's just the way she [ __ ]
hate her now yeah and you you do you
there you have a soft spot you're like
oh [ __ ] man
if only you went about it the right way
like you could have still made a
difference and you didn't have to color
your skin black well you and i
i think you and i always feel like and
i'm i'm sure you do too but like for me
i i tend to make a lot of excuses for
people who have these issues right yeah
i don't want them to [ __ ] die or
beyonce yeah
i just hate that okay she's good she's a
mess kid yeah she's a mess is she a bad
person no was she working was she
working for a good cause yes
but you have to know that that's gonna
happen to you yeah yeah you have to
think like something gotta pay a price
yeah
her intent wasn't bad to do it will
there's another doc that me and my girl
watched last night just hit netflix i
forget what it's called with this serial
killer who you know i'm balls even
serial killers but he was a serial
killer in england i don't know i know
jack to rip and all that [ __ ] but he's
serial killer in in uh in england
and he wrote a memoir like all his like
why he did it
how he did it who he did it to and he
wrote his own memoir and they have him
and the detective sitting out talking
about each death
and how he got these guys it's
nuts
16 bodies all like he was a gay man so
he'd find like homeless or runaways
and he'd go to a bar and then get him
back to the house strangle him and then
this dumbass there it is dennis nielsen
would would uh
he would stuff him underneath the
floorboards well
you can't do that because the body goes
bad and there's maggots everywhere and
stuff so the smell started to be so bad
he had so many bodies under there so
then he just started burning the bodies
and put in shovel in his backyard and
then the they're interviewing the
neighbors like weren't you like alarmed
that was having bonfires all the [ __ ]
time in the middle of the summer and
[ __ ] like i mean we just thought he was
like like fires yeah so then they go
they find out and then they're shifting
through that and there's like thousands
of bones and they're trying to identify
the bodies it's crazy have you listened
to
uh the tape recording of when the serial
killer called in to howard stern oh yeah
it's about killing 12 women yep he's
such a normal sounding guy he's like
yeah well most of the time i'd use a
hammer like like talking like he the way
he would talk about well i went and
picked up some milk and the store i'm
curious if that's real it's happened
before because there's that podcast
called the apology line yeah this guy in
new york started where hey just call get
off your chest you'll be
anonymous you no trouble so people
calling in like i cheat on my wife or a
wife calls that i cheat on my husband
you have all that and the serial killer
calls it he's like yeah i kill for this
and he goes into why he kills and stuff
like that well the guy running it was
like oh [ __ ] and they start
communicating offline like about
whatever and he's like can you prove to
me that you're actual serial killer so
he sends pictures of like dead body
stuff like that yep and it keeps going
well
he was like don't worry the cops you
know this is anonymous you have to worry
about it
so the cops clearly figured it out and
tracked the guy down and he made it all
up he had people fake like they were
dead and take pictures yeah like we
interviewed the guy for six hours he's
making all this stuff [ __ ] weird
because those fbi but at the time when
you thought it was real dude it's
fast and you're like oh [ __ ]
yeah he was like i'm actually gonna kill
tonight at midnight and i'm gonna do
this i won't give the exact location and
you're like holy [ __ ] dude it's so
intense yeah but and it's all it's six
episodes of podcasting and by the fifth
one you're so into it my six when you
find out it was all [ __ ] and it
breaks your heart i do have you seen how
they can tell when they look at a murder
scene how they can tell there was this
guy who they found like an earring
a high heel
and like i think she was buried you know
some or they just found like certain
artifacts
and they could tell that the guy
not only worked in probably a library
but also had a stutter
and they they could they traced it to
that detail because you your behavior
gives you gives you gives everything
right it gives it away
arts is going to be
quite a different subject this is
apparently people thought this was rick
flair
eating out a girl on a train because if
you see him here
does that look like rick flirty i know
it's nothing to go off of i hope it is
but does people deny that that was rick
flair
yeah
okay
that's so interesting so is this a video
i didn't see a video on here so i'm
going to look on youtube for it
and now i think this looks like
this looks like maybe she's stretching
uh
it also looks like a staged thing
probably mm-hmm
because i don't think
train video there it was train licking
uh
no i just do rick rick flair on train
train video
hello friend
and ascent that it and so
i don't know all these videos by the way
if you see where her foot is and or who
whoever's footed that is that old ass
foot does this guy show any video chin
let me check
it might just be a picture dude yeah i
think it's just a picture
yeah
yeah because why wouldn't you get video
of that they film everything else
interesting there's nothing there yeah
well the back of his head looks like ric
flair yeah yeah if it is same good for
him
is that his girl or not
that he was tonguing down i mean he's
got a tattoo on her all right
no it's a picture
so that's really nothing at all
i'm not a trained riding oral sex given
son of a gun he said that's not me
why would rick flair be on a
train yeah that's probably a better
question why would be on the train all
right why not
good for him no limousine god bless
[Music]
yeah god bless him
alrighty
next one antonio brown was thrown out of
the
a joint practice for ripping off chris
jackson's helmet
and punches him
let's see here jesus
antonio
okay there he is a beast yeah he is
what's this you know you know i did a
show with on friday terrell owens you
did
how was that it was it was it was uh it
was good yeah it's called uh hold the
popcorn
i think hold the pocket it was his
uh the guy's name is
uh hatchet hatchet hatch they come hatch
matthew hatchet it's tough because they
told me it was a podcast so you know
it's just different but it's but it was
like a tv like super high level cameras
and it was very
you know how it is when you do those
interviews it's very like
what's tough or fighting the ufc or
doing stand-up you know it's very jimmy
kimmel
where you're not having a real
conversation yeah that's kind of a
bummer yeah it's very passe i love trail
owens though
dude he's in shape uh yeah they said he
ran a 4-5 something like like literally
no
who said when he was in his primary on a
4-6-8
because i said i said he was
yeah he was never fast i love that
people always that's who told you that
no one's ever said about trail he's okay
really slow so is jerry rice wow really
jerry rice ran a 4-8 that's so
interesting because terrell i was
talking about football
and uh
i go he goes what'd you run i said i ran
a pro day round of uh
four six something four six four and his
body's like that's faster than t.o
and then he was like you guys are the
same i was like you were the exact same
man if i was just got a shot dude i
could have been [ __ ] i'd gold jacket
you know yeah trail such a monster what
a monster i remember him
so strong
i remember when he he shot jason seahorn
down jason c was so good long time ago
and he was just run out there and just
it looked like he was playing against a
guy who wasn't even in pro just
rough
yeah but they they just got to find
their footing because it's it's like
hong kong like what would you say it was
it was different they kept being like
cut and like i'd be in the military like
cut hey can you re-ask the question like
like oh his his shirt's making noise on
the mic there's too much yeah just
changed like that yeah they stopped like
about ten times i don't want to stay in
front of his staff but i want to be like
hey dude if you want to do podcasting
like really i'll help you out because
this ain't it
oh you told him that yeah you have too
much production like the the house we're
in in hollywood hills like it was just
who's the guy he's with
hatch and he was uh he played in the nfl
for eight years
yeah and he's good yeah hatch is really
good they could they should just do a
podcast like we do he was funny
he couldn't i wanted to do you can cut
all this out just rent a studio like
we're in the hollywood hills at this
this airbnb has cost him a [ __ ] arm
and a leg like the view was crazy
damn
it was just seemed on this there yeah
but yeah they're both great
geo
all right next one
wasn't she never would have even the
jamaicans was like
what oh racist all three olympic hundred
meters finishes dead last night she
finished six or nine hold on she
finished ninth in this she's the sixth
fast woman in the world okay gotcha
okay she came in ninth
and then she keeps talking [ __ ] though
i'm not upset at myself at all this is
one race i'm not done you know what i'm
capable of and count me out if you want
talk all the [ __ ] you want because i'm
here to stay i'm not done the sixth fast
woman in the game ever can't nobody ever
take that from me congratulations to the
winners but they're not done seeing me
yet period it's just tough right cause
she has all like this beats by dre
sponsored stuff so yeah her testimonial
marijuana is the best because did you
ever did you know no no
you care did you care about her before
so ironic is the best thing that could
have happened to her she probably made
what a million dollars off that i'm sure
they paid for sure but now and she's got
some weed sponsors yeah but you finish a
knife like no one's gonna sponsorship if
you're not yeah the jamaicans are like
wait what's the problem
you see that you're making a woman who's
just [ __ ]
and then there's that woman she's having
a video of them close to them the woman
the other woman who's uh who's that
woman who's from the netherlands that
blonde woman oh yeah she took like
second and she's [ __ ] but i like
shikari richardson she's sure she's a
dime piece but the thing is is it's like
the best thing that happened with the
test pilot for marijuana not racing
olympia you are correct sir yes you are
100 surprises i mean we're talking about
we have talked about her finish the
ninth if she wasn't
a storyline never never that is the
biggest thing and best thing that could
have happened she's more famous than
anybody else in the olympics besides the
nba team i know who her name is i don't
know who who won i don't know the
jamaican woman that won the goal me
neither true do you do you know the the
we had a male who finished second don't
know his name never heard of him yeah he
makes zero dollars but we know shaqari
yeah she's balling good for her that's
the thing about track you know i'm a fan
what else you got too all right there's
a thing going going around right now
that's going viral it's the crate
challenge hold on what would she run a
40 in do you think
any idea
or like that what would that jamaican
woman the fastest not fast
she so you know the like a normal like
champion state championship uh uh
sprinter would
destroy any woman in the hundred
a male high school athlete destroyer
high school destroyed
destroyed really yeah
really yeah
is there any way to see what i wonder if
they can clock what she ran a 40 in uh
that jamaica would we try to oh the
jamaican
oh i don't know
because i know that what was it what did
we do you were saying vote round four
two or something no four one but he was
just messing around
for one messing around it's [ __ ]
insane so we did look this up before oh
but not fast brian probably four eight
that's just amazing to me let's see
that's very fast by the way but four
eight that's not fast no i mean in other
words
yeah
it's not
i thought 40 40 is not their thing like
they're not they're not going to do that
like that guy tyrone kills he's the
fastest of the nfl he wants to race uh
hussein balt and hussein's like well
i'll do 60 yard dash not 40 though he
goes you put your super ball ring on the
line i put my gold medals online um
who's saying about would do destroy him
destroy him he beats everybody yeah it's
best of all times right now what are you
doing this year no problem think about
it he had sweats on at the combine i was
like yeah i'll try it and didn't warm up
around 4-1
is that true he's a freak [ __ ]
ridiculous the best man of all time dude
yeah
yeah yes what else you got jen all right
this is the milk crate challenge oh
these are hilarious you've seen this so
it's like people stack up milk crates
and they're doing the challenge and
they're getting yeah it's insanely
dangerous i don't know why they're why
people are doing this i know it doesn't
make any sense
with this
like i don't get that
[Music]
it's entertaining though yeah because
the water is way more entertaining in
the olympics it's fantastic did you see
bradley martin do it no he did it with
dumbbells and all the way up to the top
i think i saw that yeah it's on his
instagram so now what is the challenge
here i'll just play for your bro you'll
see you gotta stack them like that and
walk them and they they can support 50
pounds
so this is a successful one the
successful ones aren't fun
hey she don't know what the [ __ ] to
listen to
everybody's saying
what's she supposed to do she's just
trying to walk over get down yeah
without falling like this like this so
she did it boom
they're all crunk
go to some of the bloopers people are
breaking their arms yeah people are like
[ __ ] themselves up watch this
hold on bro use some jordan ones on tide
i ain't holding on for [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] now come on now
there's way better this one's super
funny too
because the people talking in the back
the tandem one there you go
so you gotta time it
out
some guys say this is a disaster bro i
don't know sir ain't no time on this one
you know they're trying to go around
each other
just take out them leave them alone
someone said just take your time
ain't nobody gotta rush out
[Laughter]
i think
it might be in this one they're so funny
damn they're so bad it's insane i would
never the wedding cake i would never i
would do it i don't know if the crate
would hold my big ass though
wow
all right hold on they were hyped for
him he had it for him
go down chin what's up go down there's
another one
oh this one's insane yeah this one's
like the original oh that's on not good
ground this is the original one
dude
this is the music
this is when you got you're just bored
as [ __ ] my thing is bad where'd he get
all these milk crate from
oh
that was bad that was like i didn't see
it i was looking at you guys
that was really good
does he scorpion it dude
being watched he's just the way he hits
the back scorpion oh god
you get paralyzed like that uh you can
definitely have a very bad back like
that that'll [ __ ] your back they're
fantastic though how much more
entertaining is that than the real
olympics
[ __ ] man god it's great
i feel like you could do a b you're
light-footed you could do it no i'm not
going to do it i'm a little too old
though because then if i fall something
bad happens is there any white people
doing it nope you're probably my family
is the only one that feels like a white
guy thing to do though yeah that's what
i'm saying i'm like that
because he called the hood olympics
no they don't yeah they do yeah they do
yeah they do it's called the crate
challenge not the hood i'm telling this
is hashtag
hood olympics damn where's bradley at
here we go oh this first is one of the
christians found
oh i saw this one who didn't turn your
camera around
now first of all he's barefoot okay
oh
[ __ ] look he's all damn at least it
landed flat
that's that's a better one
yeah
go to bradley i think barefoot's the way
to do it i definitely knocked the wind
that guy could not breathe after that
i just feel like i'm too big for it
yeah i i don't like the prospects of you
falling on that oh i thought he was
doing on weights
who is this bradley martin oh but he's
oh he's the uh guru that's my boy yeah
okay is that zoo culture yeah
all right
oh wow well that's impressive bradley
you got to be careful bradley because
this is exactly how you can break your
[ __ ]
oh boy look are those 25 pound dumbbells
still though no one's done it no no i
wouldn't even try it
i would just throw him to the ground
bradley yeah then she gives him his food
she has some diapers give him food
she's beautiful by the way
not that i'm noticing but i'm just
saying that's how you look oh he did
that easily
was he was he an athlete no not not like
an actual athlete but you know like a
hood athlete
that was pretty easy for him yeah
it's just balance
that's a going core
core strength those are good well i just
got me all tight right now could you do
it ryan i would i think i could do it
easy i mean i can do a good core
strength maybe you know what i tried to
do i tried doing the when you have that
band that's tied between
what's it called the slack chord
oh the band that's like on bro i try i
mean i got to a point where i could
almost go all the way but it's [ __ ]
it took me an hour
to brazil it's all over what about that
guy ito portal remember that guy was
thinking about him who is the movement
mcgregor's movement coach
yeah there's his website
he cut his hair he cut his hair
and he's still moving there he is
he's got a he's a he's a little guy but
he's in shape
okay looks very different
well his body's not great anymore
it's just that angle
hell yeah
[Music]
[ __ ] when connor was doing this [ __ ]
though we were all sold on it
you actually weren't no you were super
careful
i don't buy it he's very little guy i
guess he um he was doing one arm pull-up
so that was what i thought was cool
you just dancing there yeah what is this
now
[ __ ] come get something
amazing
dude see if he'll do your video first of
all
and you just [ __ ] jam out
a movement coach hell yeah that's sick
we don't need more channels all right
all right kids uh
la jolla the comic store this thursday
friday saturday probably gonna add a
show to thursday so get your tickets at
f a t k z dot com and then the week
after that i'm off i'm on vacation then
i'm in san jose california september 9th
through the 11th then the big boy san
antonio bud light event center right
outside the atg arena september 24th one
show september 25th one show and then
denver colorado september 30th through
october 2nd
but this week la jolla comedy store come
get some boom
you're not with us on thursday right
yeah thursday i'll be at bray improv uh
one night august 26th then i'll be
meeting up with brendan and the rest of
the guys yeah friday and saturday in la
jolla you're so friendly though and then
uh yeah
and then uh september 9th i'll be at
cobb's comedy club in uh san francisco
nice uh come see me in buffalo kids
september 9th through 11th at helium i
got denver colorado the 23rd 24th 25th
i'm excited and the end of september uh
september uh 30th not 28th but 30th to
october 2nd chicago illinois
by the way my tourist call made these i
put my tour is called the political
moderate tour yeah and uh it's going to
go moderately his opener is dan krishna
shut the [ __ ] up
in the middle politically hey i'm doing
a thing i think on for my patreon
followers um i'm gonna do i'm gonna
start something called colin callan
where i'm gonna do a podcast where you
guys can call in
and ask me questions and i will talk to
you and it should be fun i want to see
where it goes it should be an
interesting thing we're still trying to
figure it out but that's coming soon and
there's a fight campaign this sunday
calabasas fight companion it's gonna be
rampage jackson brian callan josh
thompson myself that starts at 5 p.m
pacific
only on the thick boy channel and that's
for the wood leavers jake paul fight
this sunday that's it kids love you all
right